[Music]
[Music]
i am
[Music]
plus i am
[Music]
good morning
welcome back to the best business show
i don't know what the hell was going on
here yesterday but i'm back
i took a red eye to get back i slept
four and a half hours i got enough
coffee here to kill a young child
and i'm ready to go
joe is not here
there was a mutiny yesterday i saw the
memes i saw the whole i'm the captain
now you ain't the captain you're out
you're not here i am here with john
though
john's right there his name's on the
back of his chair polina's here too
name's on the back of her chair
there she is there she is looking as
smart beautiful doing the royal weight
and nice as possible nice
we're not gonna play any games
i saw this shirt yesterday
these shirts i've confiscated all of
them
get the [ __ ] out of here
uh all right sorry kid show
not a lot of sleep sometimes you just
got to say what you got to say we got a
bunch of stuff to start with
one
go to sofi.com sofi makes all this
possible
we're tired we've been doing a lot of
work go download the app please sofi.com
they're giving you free bitcoin bitcoins
down in price a little bit that means
that you can get more bitcoin if you go
right now buy ten dollars worth of
bitcoin on so far they'll give you ten
dollars for free pretty good deal
sofi.com make sure you read the terms
and conditions a lawyer better not call
me today today is not the day to call me
second
is
merch
what did you guys do yesterday with
merch did you give any away
uh yeah yeah well you're supposed to
sound like a little quiet mouse over
there you were supposed to pick the
winners oh really yeah from where we'll
pick them today all right
we'll pick the winners by the way from
the fire pump hashtag that we tweeted it
that we shark attacked you with anyone
who tweeted fire pomp at me he's getting
back on twitter
about that who's laughing now
see this is what happens it's like when
uh it's like when your parents leave you
at home with a babysitter and they leave
and the babysitter's like all right
let's uh everyone behave and me and my
brothers would go wild i mean we would
destroy the house and beat each other up
the babysitter legit one time quit in
the middle of the night chris was crying
and called my parents anthony was like
15.
like 13 yeah
and i remember that at the end of the
night what does that everyone do
they literally negotiate with the
babysitter as your parents are pulling
them in the bedroom and you are in the
driveway we would say okay all right
here's the deal i just told them we
behaved and and we promised that we
won't tell them that you're a bad person
basically what we'd be like we're gonna
tell your bad person if you say anything
bad about us we used to blackmail our
babysitter for sure facts
listen how do you how do you compete
with a 12 year old who's blackmailing
you you can't
we got a lot to talk about
before we do that we're 132 likes
yesterday they were supposed to give
away 10 000 in bitcoin if they got to 3
000 concurrents
didn't get the 2k
ah what happened we get to 2k likes
i thought it was a great show yesterday
i think people liked it as well
uh
people are asking where's joe
joe joe's out
private jet joe was making a lot of
jokes about you yesterday yeah it's all
right it's fine he also was over here i
came back my computer was all messed up
the internet wasn't even plugged into
the computer anymore i was like not only
did the guy try to mess with me
yesterday he's trying to sabotage me
today
it's all right we're all good we're all
good it's all fun and games no problem
uh by the way american airlines greatest
airline in the world no free advertising
two strikes on this trip
on the way there no wi-fi strike one on
the way back on the red eye no blinking
and pillow strike two
wait wait can i tell the people so um he
called me this morning he was like i
just landed and he sounded like
exhausted and i was like are you okay he
was like four hour flight no blanket
really
that's brutal listen i need my sleep i
didn't get sleep it's fine but i'm here
i took the red eye back specifically to
do this i had to come back after joe's
nonsense yesterday that's fine i don't
know by the way how somehow john is
letting joe take all the heat but i know
john was involved look at this
grin that little greedy grin
i was definitely involved in a lot of
the jokes the t-shirts
it's all right
sorry all right ukraine
passed yesterday a law to legalize
crypto currencies uh if you think about
this it's pretty crazy that it wasn't
legal already uh but the main purpose uh
behind the bill is to provide
clarification on the asset and protect
those who owned bitcoin as it was not
previously legal um or illegal so
basically it was up in the air nobody
knew uh but this bill gives the citizens
permission to own and trade bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies on exchanges
according to the bill
this law
regulates legal relations arising in
connection with the turnover of virtual
assets in ukraine defines the rights and
obligations of participants in the
virtual assets market the principles of
state policy in the field of virtual
assets
what
every time i read anything that a
government writes i just said why can't
they just write in plain english why
they got to make it so confusing this
law regulates legal relations what the
hell is a legal relationship i did not
have sexual relations with that woman
come on what is this legal relationship
just say that the law allows people to
buy and sell bitcoin like i look there
you go i solved your problem the page
would be so much shorter if you just
wrote it in english
uh you're salty today i'm just gonna
call it how it is today today is one of
those days where there's no filter i'm
just going to say what i what i think
bill was drafted last year it passed
with 276 lawmakers supporting the law
only six were against it those six must
be boomers this is the fifth country in
the last few weeks to lay down some
ground rules for the cryptocurrency
market obviously el salvador made it
legal tender cuba passed a law to
recognize well we got a spell recognized
right there maybe next time and regulate
cryptocurrencies panama's kicking around
a draft of its own cryptocurrency law
and then ukraine is the second largest
country by size eighth by population in
europe and yeah uh in europe and they've
got 45 million people as of 2019.
when you when you look at this there's a
couple of things that immediately pop to
mind first
the bills are written in a ridiculous
legal legalese language that no one
understands so they probably would be
better off they changed that two it is
not lost on me that the country of
ukraine is giving permission to their
citizens to use a permissionless
technology
the law doesn't matter
for the technology to be used or not now
they can go after people right in
nigeria or pakistan where they actually
have banned or outlawed bitcoin they can
go and they can try to put people in
jail they can regulate businesses et
cetera but they can't stop people from
using the technology it's a
permissionless technology you do not
need permission to access it and so the
idea that the country gives people
permission is quite
funny there's irony to it
go ahead planet i have a question go
ahead how would
ukraine know if i as a private citizen
hold bitcoin because isn't it kind of
like how would they know that so that
part of it i think is uh
they almost are forced to make it legal
because
if they're trying to look at like
exchange let's say there's a ukrainian a
ukrainian right a ukraine based exchange
uh they can obviously
the equivalent of subpoena in ukraine
maybe they don't actually have as much
of a democratic kind of legal process as
they do here in the united states but
they can basically go and get the
customer list right then they know hey
who signed up for an account who's
buying and selling this stuff etc
if it is on a peer-to-peer decentralized
uh exchange they may not actually be
able to do that
and then i'm sure that they've got some
other things where they're basically
looking hey who's actually uh consuming
lots of energy right now that energy
consumption must mean that they're
bitcoin mining let's go check it out not
the purchasers miners i mean there's a
bunch of different things that they
could do to try to to try to identify it
this just makes it much easier right
remember bitcoin is good for business
and so if you're a country you can tax
it you can get job creation in your
country right you can get a lot of um
kind of economic value that comes from
this
and so in most cases i think countries
will eventually capitulate and they'll
have to embrace it
the idea that they give permission
though is pretty funny and then lastly
is
when you think of ukraine uh i think i
saw stat
that said ukraine is the
fourth most popular
country hold on we're gonna do some live
research real quick uh let me see if i
can find this real quick now that i'm
thinking about it
according to chain analysis ukraine is
fourth worldwide when it comes to per
capita crypto adoption
that's pretty big right nick carter
posted a uh chain analysis uh blog so
ukraine is the fourth worldwide when it
comes to per capita crypto adoption so
very very large crypto adoption
and so i think that
this is ultimately like the will of the
people wins right if you remember like
uh uber when uber went to new york city
the people loved it they were like oh my
god taxis suck uber's so much better
let's all use uber and uber was also
subsidizing both the riders fare and
also the driver so the drivers getting
paid more money the writers loved it
because it was cheap uh it was better
than a taxi et cetera well the
government hated uber and the taxi
unions were up in arms they were
protesting all kinds of crazy stuff
trying to get ubered out of new york and
so what did uber say uber said well we
have the people on our side and they
simply when you would pull up the app it
would basically be a blank screen it
would say if the government is
successful this is what the the app will
look like and so instead go sign up
petition go protest go you know like
basically let's use the button there's a
button that you could press to
participate i think bradley tusk was a
was a huge piece of that uh shout out
bradley um and so when you think about
somewhere like ukraine
if you have the fourth highest per
capita crypto adoption anywhere in the
world
eventually you just say look are we
really going to go against what the
people want
right and it kind of leads to the
conversation here in the united states
like there's regulators who
are basically making decisions that are
actually hurting
the population
in the united states there are
geo-fenced assets
there are yield assets that a u.s
consumer is not supposedly able to
access
how much money did the u.s consumers not
make because the regulation
in many cases you would have made more
money by simply participating in the
crypto system
than they gave in stimulus checks
so you have to look at what is the will
of the people what do the people want
the government especially in democratic
environments serves at the will of the
people
the people should not fear the
government the government should fear
the people and so when you think of it
from that perspective ukraine most
likely is just simply saying hey we have
people who want to use this and so we've
got to make it legal we've got to
provide clarification to the rules
and so when i look through kind of how
they're doing it what they did not do
was they did not make it legal tender
they did not do what el salvador did
they simply said it is legal for you to
buy it sell it hold it and it is also
legal for bless you excuse me and it is
also legal for you to uh run a business
that is related to it
which is kind of a first step towards
the country actually doing something but
it's essentially the equivalent of the
united states right it is legal for you
to buy and sell bitcoin in the united
states it is legal for you to build a
business around it and uh that's
essentially what they're doing right
here the economy in the ukraine is
massive especially when you think about
these other countries that have adopted
bitcoin right so el salvador for example
their gdp is 27 billion in 2019 and
ukraine's is 154 billion so it's very
very important i think the making of
these laws uh one thing i also want to
make clear because even just like the
way people were wording tweets yesterday
which i think trying to trick people in
the sense of that it was legal tender
and obviously it is not legal tender
they just legalized the operations for
individuals and businesses
but look all these laws they can help
regulate what's happening in the space
um and they can make these clear-cut
rules of hey this is loud this isn't
allowed or really complicated rules as
we see lawmakers like to do but it also
tramples innovation in the space right
so when you stop something from being
adopted it actually hurts your country i
think more um than the other side of
things
do we think uh plano our resident
eastern european expert uh do we think
that there's an element of the past like
history across eastern europe and that
plays into their trust of the government
yeah like does that does that play in so
for those that don't know plano was born
in bulgaria beautiful country beautiful
country and they've been there multiple
times
basically a bulgarian at this point um
do we think that
the relationship people have with the
government ends up driving an interest
in this stuff
you know
maybe uh we went to when we went to
bulgaria we had like a crypto meetup and
i i was surprised by how many people
were working on crypto projects or
blockchain related companies um
i don't know i actually
i i do think that there's probably a
link to the
government aspect to it but like what
about russia have they done anything
what
uh what i will say is i'm laughing
all right i'll tell the story oh god
oh no
i can't believe i'm about to tell a
story um
in 2018
i went to uh singapore
with a uh and i met a bunch of people
when i was there and in singapore uh
an american friend of mine who i will
not name
said to me uh
you know
i have this business uh i have two or
three partners um we should all go to
dinner
great
so we met for dinner
and uh
his partners came they were both russian
they did not speak the entire dinner
they just sat there and they reminded me
of uh
uh ivan drago right he's from the rocky
movies is that that's what i don't know
him but sure isn't that the boxer from
russia probably john's looking at me
like i'm crazy you're gonna hate i've
never seen rock hold on what
i've never seen rocky i've seen snippets
oh wait no no no bro come on felina
tells me all the time she hasn't seen
certain movies and that's because she
didn't grow up in the american culture
for the first 10 years of her life
bro you lived in the same house as me
he is a soviet russian fictional
character from the rocky film series all
right yeah so he's from rocky so
i know the whole thing like where he
does that on the stairs
we this weekend we're going to watch
every rocky movie all the way through
yeah there's enough all right so we go
to dinner they don't talk the whole time
nice guys whatever
we leave
we come the next day and he's like hey
meet me for lunch
and i show up to a restaurant
that's closed
uh
at the top floor of a high rise
and i walk into the room
and where first i walk into the
restaurant and they're like server
clothes and i'm like uh
i think i'm here to see somebody and
they're like who and i say the name i'm
like oh yes right away and they bring me
to this back room
and it turns out that uh one of these
guys owns the restaurant and so they're
having this like private meeting in this
private room and so now oh my god this
is like the restaurant's closed like
what so i walk in the room
and it's like they multiplied now
there's like
30 russian guys
and as soon as i walk in the room
everyone stops talking and everyone
leaves except for the two guys and my
buddy
it was a very short meeting
i basically left as soon as i could
and my take on the whole thing was the
following
russians
love bitcoin
this is right up their alley this is
something that they absolutely
understand
they get
but the way that that culture works is
it's very uh
bottoms up in this type of adoption
and
the
people at the top as in many countries
around the world aren't necessarily
going to decree down
legal not legal do this do that whatever
because they don't want to take a
position on it but there's a lot of
participation in russia i'm sure we
could actually pull up uh the data on
russia specifically
in terms of uh let's see russian usage
of bitcoin and let's
see there's
for those that don't know john
that is even drago is that the bad guy
in the movie huh is that the bad guy in
the movie
yeah oh so how is he how is he a
fictional character but he's got his own
wikipedia page like i am a real
character and i don't have a wikipedia
you're a charac you're a character
huh you're a character yeah all right
uh so a lot of the articles about russia
are specifically around that they are
going to be a big recipient of the china
ban on mining where people are going to
flow they're going to go to uh to russia
a lot of energy a lot of cheap energy uh
it's cold a whole bunch of advantages
there um and then also at one point uh i
think russia was thinking about banning
it but it seems like they uh they backed
off of that and in 2020 they uh gave
bitcoin legal status but they banned uh
digital assets from being used in
payments
so uh you know interesting relationship
there um the other piece of this is it's
not just ukraine though so uh if we pull
up i think i saw matt pull up earlier
there's this uh tweet uh one of the
co-authors of the bill uh from uh
ukraine standing in front of
the
house and then this is panama
panama has introduced a bill to promote
the use of cryptocurrency and other
digital assets similar to legislation
and its fellow central american country
el salvador bill is designed to provide
like a legal regulatory and fiscal
certainty to the use holding an issuance
of digital value in crypto assets in the
republic of panama
gabrielle silva
coming in hot we have a friend who who
is kind of friends with him
yes true i've actually talked to this
guy i'm trying to get him on the podcast
but i dropped the ball so we'll uh we'll
uh my two-month prediction of
another country making bitcoin legal
tender is looking pretty good right now
i saw somebody tweet this at us and then
i you dm'd it to me and said check the
receipts
so the prediction that you had was
within two months after el salvador
someone would propose a bill to make it
legal
before we get this nonsense is john did
not say that we were going to get a bill
proposing you said another country would
make it legal tender it took two months
for since the bill passed for el
salvador to actually have it as legal
tender as well listen
the uh
legal tender
is not happening in panama yet it may
happen it's on the way we'll see
we will see
um what do we think about panama fast
following it feels to me like that's
kind of a no-brainer right yeah this
this is all going to be a no-brainer
right crypto's here to stay it seems
like and the more and more uh that
government and countries kind of
legalize it and adopt it and put it into
the you know their tax bills anything
like that uh it just proves the validity
of the asset and that's what we're
seeing every single country i think
around the world will eventually do it
um some will lag others but it's just
it's inevitable at this point plano what
do you think about uh ukraine panama etc
yeah i think it's interesting i think
most people would be like who cares that
those countries did that but i it does
you know kind of
uh
become an example in other countries
like i think panama was watching closely
what el salvador did and same
might happen with ukraine my question is
once these things start happening on
like a legal level is the sec and those
regulatory institutions are is that what
they're waiting for to kind of pass
guidance or are they their own thing and
they don't care if it's legalized or not
inside of these countries
um
i think there's basically
four different states that us that a
country can be in the first state is we
like this it's legal knock yourself out
yeah the second state is we hate this
it's banned get out
the third state is we banned it but
everyone's still using it and adoption
exploded nigeria pakistan etc
and then the fourth state is uh we are
not gonna make a decision yet and
therefore there's gonna be lots of
uncertainty so it's like
embrace it ban it ban it but it doesn't
work or basically leave it uncertain
right
and
if you think about the countries that
are embracing this they're not exactly
the countries that you would immediately
think of i said hey who's the most
technologically advanced who's the most
developed nation right it's not the
united states
it's not you know uh france or uh the uk
or somewhere like that it's el salvador
and that's not a knock on the people of
el salvador because what they realize is
hey we're a third world country we're a
developing nation
we can use this to leapfrog into the
first world order and so they're
basically saying
our
previously perceived disadvantage
is actually going to be an advantage
because we can move fast we've
consolidated government
and we're dollarized so we don't have
the innovator's dilemma of if we embrace
bitcoin then we might hear our own
currency
so they recognize that they have a very
unique position and they're going to use
that to their advantage
ukraine
other places like that again panama
these are not places that people think
oh that's a technology hub that's a
place that is super affordable they
could flip right
of course
the united states at one point was the
challenger we literally fought a war
over to get away from
the the king cuba has historically kind
of not adopted innovation in a lot of
aspects right and they're legalizing
bitcoin
people don't like when i say this
oh boy
when you have a permissionless system
anyone can use it
and that means
good people will use it and bad people
will use it developed nations will use
it and developing nations will use it
first world third world corporations
individuals everyone has the ability to
use it
and so when you look at it from an
incentive standpoint the developing
nations have more to gain by embracing
this than the developed nations and so
in the united states
we are literally arguing over
securities laws again i don't know how
it's going to play out like whatever the
the sec uh i do think that there are
people there that are trying their best
to figure it out and kind of do the work
they need to do there's people that are
in the private sector they're trying the
best to figure it out and like it'll get
figured out right
but these other countries there's nobody
in el salvador who's talking about
securities law they're literally talking
about how do we create economic
prosperity for millions of citizens who
live in poverty who have 80 percent
unbanked
who i saw a statistic today that the
chivo wallet i don't know matt if we can
if we can find the chiva wallet on
twitter uh they quote retweeted
something where western union is
estimated that they're going to lose 400
million dollars in revenue simply
because the country of el salvador is
moving to bitcoin rails
so when that happens
you start to actually take down legacy
financial firms
but it's the developing nations that are
incentivized to do this not the
developed nations
viewer aaron asks pomp enlighten us on
what's happening in nigeria
anthony loves nigeria
i went to nigeria
in
2015 i think it was or 26 maybe it was
2016.
and uh when i went to nigeria um i
didn't know what to expect frankly uh
you know there's a part of me that had
like my western world brain which was uh
i'm going to a country in africa um it's
not going to be very developed uh
there's not going to be a lot of
internet penetration
i need to be careful um you know just
just kind of all the things that you
would expect of hey i'm going to this
country in africa that i've never been
to before i don't know anybody i don't
speak the language etc
the other side of my brain was really
excited because i was reading online
about the demographics and a bunch of
young people and and them trying to be
more technologically forward et cetera
when i went it was absolutely
mind-blowing uh not only is there a very
young population and the demographics
are probably some of the best anywhere
but nigeria from a population standpoint
uh is growing so fast about 200 million
uh citizens today and at the rate that
they're growing they will have more
citizens in nigeria than the united
states by 2050. wow so when you look at
the growth rate of that country it's
incredibly compelling and so there's
naturally a lot of very young people
there
uh but also there's great internet
penetration and mobile phone penetration
and so what ended up happening is uh
there's a place called victoria island
uh victoria island is basically where
all the tourists go stay uh i for better
or worse didn't do that uh mainly
because i didn't know
and i think i was being cheap and i was
like oh those hotels are too expensive
let me get a different hotel uh and so
a buddy of mine and i stayed
in lagos and we stayed about a mile away
from a place called computer village and
computer village is the best way that i
can describe it
it's like if you've ever gone to a flea
market right or like like a you know
like a swap meet or something
on like massive steroids so what it
basically is is maybe
uh i'll estimate like maybe it's like
eight to ten blocks by eight to ten
blocks packed in
and as you're walking around this market
there's electronics everywhere and
there's all kinds of other goods and
services being sold and bartered or
whatever
but in this place what you realize is
they're selling all the latest
smartphones they're selling laptops all
kinds of electronics you know the
equivalent of like boom boxes that you
would have like at your house or
whatever all that type of stuff
and so
as i was walking around there i realized
and i actually wrote a piece publicly
after i came back this is the future of
the consumer internet
it is not in the united states right
when i left facebook in 2015
85 of facebook's user base was outside
the united states that's crazy and so we
think in the western world about the u.s
being this really important market and
what you used to do is used to start a
company you would penetrate the us
market and then you would literally hold
like a board meeting and you would be
like
2021 this is the year of international
expansion we are going to put a lot of
money behind this and we're going to go
expand internationally
now what do people do
they literally build a technology
company when they turn it on on day one
it's global and so there is no kind of
sequential like world domination there
is no penetrate u.s market then go
elsewhere instead what happens is you
turn on a company it's global on day one
and what we're starting to find out is
there's other places in the world where
they see the value of
this technology so whether it's in asia
where there's lots of speculation and
trading and they love the 24 7 365
market and all that type of stuff
or it's somewhere like in an african
country where they're saying hey our
currency is being devalued we have great
internet and mobile phone penetration
and we think that this technology can
really help us or it's a place like el
salvador right ukraine
panama like the places that you're
hearing about are not the places that
you would normally expect
nigeria on a per capita basis is number
one in terms of uh what they are uh or
in terms of the crypto adoption uh
they're they're number one i think um on
a per capita basis and i think they're
number two in aggregate size
if i remember the data correctly and so
they just a lot of people there really
really see the value in bitcoin
cryptocurrencies and they're going to
continue to use it
we have this tweet here from
mackenzie from cnbc said if you want to
send 10 from canada el salvador via
western union's app it's a 3.24
fee
from the moon wallet to the chivo wallet
it's 10 cents chivo de chivo it's free
kelly's new bitcoin wallet could cost
companies like western union 400 400
million dollars a year
see ya we already held the funeral for
western union i'm sure you guys are nice
people but you're dead to us so so this
is exactly kind of like the vision of
what the blockchain could be is that you
cut out the middleman
and
the people it doesn't fall on the people
right well so there's two key things to
take away from this right and this is
really important if you're watching at
home right now we're gonna start getting
into some of the weeds over the next
couple of shows about uh some of the the
ways from like an investor perspective
you can understand that the trend is our
friend when it comes to uh to bitcoin
and not just around price so for example
let's start first with just the fees
when you look at a piece of technology
what you're looking for is a 10x or more
improvement right you can't just simply
have a
2x improvement from a technology
perspective or it's too evolutionary
what you need is for real technology to
have true disruption as you need 10x or
more
and some of that is qualitative like you
just kind of feel like hey this is so
much better but some of it is also
quantitative and so look being able to
look at the fees for example and say
wait it's a 3.24 fee if i use legacy
system it's 10 cents if i use this
system then that's a 10x improvement you
really understand like oh wow this is
super disruptive right
the second thing is
in the legacy system if i go to western
union and i want to send
money to somebody in el salvador i have
to send from western union to western
union there's no western union to chase
bank or western union to something else
it's western union to western union in
the united states if i'm on venmo and
john's on cash app i can't venmo john
and he receives it on cash app they're
all closed networks
what the bitcoin network and the
lightning network allow for is an open
network and so now all of a sudden what
can happen is that i could be on the
moon wallet john could be on the chibo
wallet and even though i'm using a
different interface i can still use the
bitcoin network of the lightning network
and i can send value to john and he
receives it in his app or his interface
but we our two companies the companies
that we're using they don't even talk to
each other they don't even know anything
about each other right they don't have a
partnership don't have any of this stuff
and so when you look at a 10x
improvement on technology you look at an
open system versus a closed system it's
very clear that there's going to be
massive disruption in the payment sector
uh because ultimately there's a
financial incentive and there's a user
experience incentive that allows you to
uh
transact with more people in a more
efficient way faster and cheaper if it's
cheap convenient and secure people were
gonna follow the technology of course
why would you pay and by the way we were
just talking i think was a hundred
dollars is what uh mackenzie was talking
about it's a three dollar fee right
yeah oh i'm sorry ten dollars so so
think about this if you want to send ten
dollars you pay 30
fees
30
fees
you want to talk about some nefarious
ass [ __ ]
there you go
if somebody wants to send ten dollars
from canada to el salvador they pay 30
percent two people that need it into a
country that needs it
yeah and it's also not instant right
like
to be honest it's robbery to be honest
it kind of just pisses me off right
because what you start to realize is
it's like the banks the top four banks
made eight billion dollars in 2019 off
of overdraft fees they took eight
billion dollars from people who didn't
have money
same thing here if you're sending 10
across western union you're probably not
super well off
and the person that you're sending it to
probably really needs the money
but you charge 3024 yeah the problem is
though is uh this is their only option
right as of right now like the only
store historically that has been their
only option and the unfortunate part is
it's almost like you signed up for it
right so when you sign up for a bank
you're agreeing to hey if i overdraft my
account you can charge me that fee but
it's the people that don't really have a
lot of options to go to and they're like
hey look i need to set up an account
this bank i need to use this kind of
service um and i'm willing to accept
those fees even knowing sometimes hey
look i'm gonna i'm gonna run into that
issue later and i'll deal with it when i
get there
the other piece of this that i think no
one's really talking about uh is
as you drop costs so aggressively and
you create an open network what this is
going to do is it's going to uh spread
very virally money is the most viral
product in the world right and so if all
of a sudden now i can plug into a open
network and so can all of you
when i plug into that open network i can
send money to any of you but also every
single business that now joins i can do
it as well and so you're basically using
this common infrastructure in a way that
doesn't require intense centralized
coordination everyone is financially
incentivized to see the system work but
everyone does it on their own
perspective so you plug in your node
and you don't care if i have a node set
up or not as long as you plug into the
system the more nodes that are set up
the more coverage there is the more
coverage there is actually the more
efficiency there becomes and so what you
start to do is the network gets built
out by every individual participant and
the equal parts or like the total of the
sum
ends up being so much better right think
about this for a second
12 years ago bitcoin was created
today
a nation state has onboarded not to just
layer one but to layer to the lightning
network
an entire country is now saying they're
gonna use lightning network
and so you have mcdonald's right
starbucks big corporations do lots of
transactions you can go there right now
and you can buy items in the country as
legal tender using bitcoin the lightning
network is super exciting we're going to
do a whole segment on that one day
this reminds me of like the internet
in what way how long did it take
for countries to like take the world
wide web seriously
like you're asking all the great
questions guys the way you laughed at
that
you're saying how long did it take for
at what point was the internet kind of
what bitcoin and how we're talking about
the lightning network and all these
things now for global adoption right now
nodes and yeah you have to remember that
a lot of people when they first saw the
internet
they couldn't wrap their head around the
use cases right
right so there's obviously the famous
video i think it's like brian gumbel
and a couple people and they're like
internet what's the internet all right
and they like are talking about it
you know you're like they're like the
internet and you're like no it's just
internet they're like
what is this the internet right and
you're everyone just like laughs about
the videos now
or there's paul krugman who was like you
know the internet will never be more
useful than to send like a or never be
more useful than a fax machine or
something and so what happens is humans
have a really really hard time
extrapolating out a technology shift or
like a paradigm shift and how that will
actually end up being um
implemented later or like the the impact
that it has later and so
bitcoin is like the manifestation of
that today where
who would have thought
that
50 plus percent of commerce in the
united states
would be on the internet now
who would have thought that eventually
you would press a button on your phone
and a car would show up
who would have thought that during a
global pandemic people could sit in
their home and order food and so it
would deliver it to them right who would
have thought that amazon would end up
getting into same-day delivery
like these things are insane if you're
talking about it in 1990s
today we're like yeah duh of course like
hindsight 2020. of course that was going
to happen
chivo wall is the two i was looking for
earlier
cnbc said el salvador's new bitcoin
wallet could cost western union 400
million dollars a year chivo wallet
sorry not sorry boys
i mean just expert level trolling right
now and so look at the end of the day
this is what it takes it takes people to
build technology takes people to
actually go out there do the work but
the writings on the wall the legacy
payment systems they have a choice
embrace the new technology
that's all this is this technology
embrace the new technology or get
disrupted classic innovators dilemma and
usually what happens in the innovator's
dilemma is that the legacy incumbent
businesses do not embrace the new
technology because it will eat away at
their
current business if western union was to
go ahead and embrace bitcoin it could
hurt them to the tune of hundreds of
millions if not billions of dollars a
year across the world
and so
are you going to make a decision as an
executive who you're graded by the stock
performance in the short term
that is going to hurt your stock price
today for the long-term sustainability
and durability of your business usually
not and so what ultimately will happen
is they will continue to milk it as much
as they can they'll take as much revenue
as they possibly can but ultimately
they're just running off a cliff and
they'll end up getting disrupted so i
think all executives if you're making
that decision right there of hey do i
make a basically a cultural and
innovation shift into this new
technology to help the longevity and the
sustainability of my business long term
versus hey i think the stock price might
crash today i think everyone should make
the decision for long term
well of course but nobody does
right
everyone for the most part again this
isn't true of everyone but for the most
part executives who especially have to
have their compensation tied to the
stock price
it's just human nature right the
incentive is keep the stock price up
okay how do i keep the stock price if i
keep revenue up how do i keep revenue up
i do more of what we're already doing i
don't go ahead and destroy my existing
business for the long-term
sustainability i might not be here in 10
years when that's the problem is a lot
of them know they're like hey i may not
be here in 10 years to actually reap the
benefits of it of course
all right we got we have a surprise for
everyone ooh
i haven't told anybody yet we we have
two guests coming on today oh thank you
they were gonna say you brought us gifts
from wherever you were no
that was
uneventful yeah i i brought you a gift
it's the t-shirt on the floor it's this
fire pump
i have mine we got you a gift while
you're gone yeah yeah i appreciate it uh
we have two guests coming on today in
about 20 minutes
ricky williams yes the nfl legend ricky
williams is going to join us live to
talk about a couple of things he's
working on uh for anybody who is a
football fan uh this one's gonna be fun
uh we're an nft fan yeah we're
definitely gonna have to ask him about
when they tracked him down in australia
you know about the story oh man all
right you google it real quick ricky
williams australia learn ricky he'll
give us the real estate yeah yeah
uh so rick williams gonna come on and
then after that uh we've got uh dan
tapario who's gonna come on he recently
just announced that he raised 750
million dollars from a whole bunch of
wall street billionaires uh large
institutions uh and he's been deploying
the capital very very quickly into the
market so we're gonna go ahead and we're
gonna talk about uh
uh that as well so two great guests for
us today
make sure that you're hitting the like
button let's see where we're at 600
likes let's go if we get the 2k likes
i'll give away a bunch of merch today we
got to 2k likes yesterday yeah
and that's individual likes
what
like i mean like
what is going on today i don't know
anything i'm delirious because i didn't
sleep you guys slept a bunch and you
guys are acting weird no but you know
what i mean
about like you only get one like per
username oh they're like you need
they're like unique like that's what i
said yeah
that's true that's true also uh angelo
commented here and i agree with him
it is not eggspecially it's especially
it's not egg espresso it's espresso
who said egg especially
let's move on
i can say it however i want angelo what
do you know
angelo might not even be the way you
pronounce your name maybe we're screwing
up your name and then you're gonna get
upset or not
all right
make sure you smash the like button
let's keep it rolling uh next oh man
damn john's just laying john knew that i
was gonna be uh ready to rock and roll
today and he just put topics in here
that just serve up softball after
softball to me
the white house
what happened the white house had a
press conference yesterday
uh
and
joe biden's national economic council
brian dees
i feel bad for this man yeah i feel bad
for him too we're not gonna play the
video because it's kind of boring but
he said
that if you don't count beef pork and
poultry
then grocery prices are haven't even
really increased that much
brian i'm sure you're a nice guy this
isn't meant for you i'm sure you're just
getting the talking point someone's
handing you a piece of paper before you
go up there so does he mean like lamb
but if you take out the groceries from
the grocery price index then the prices
never increase let's just take all the
food out why stop at just the uh beef
pork and poultry [ __ ] let's take out
milk and eggs and bread maybe we'll take
out rice as well
broccoli you're out of there apples and
bananas you're out just take all the
food out of the grocery price index and
the prices will never increase he said
we've never leave fresh fruit it's
actually going down
jesus christ this is the nonsense that
goes on
inflation is here and if they are going
to tell us it's not they're liars at
this point it's no longer oh we don't
know oh maybe it's going to be higher
than we think they know it's here and
the stuff that they'll do is they'll do
two things they'll one gaslight us which
we talked about last week which is
they'll say to us oh this has always
been in line with the things that we've
been saying as we went back and proved
that's not true
second is they'll do this which is the
way that they count the numbers they'll
start to manipulate it so they'll try to
show a number that's not as high so for
example if you look at the cpi number
the core price index number the core
price index is over five percent then
they'll come out say oh but core
inflation core inflation or i'm sorry
the consumer price index they'll say
core inflation which is basically to
take off food and gas or food and energy
and so that's only four and a half
percent 4.3 percent you're like wait a
minute why are we taking out food and
energy isn't that part of the consumer
prices and so they'll start to
manipulate the number now what they're
doing is they're saying oh groceries are
up a lot how do we actually get the
consumer price index down or core uh
down
you know what we could do let's go into
the grocery prices and let's take out
some of the groceries take out the
highest the highest increasing
prices yeah it's like [ __ ] as an
investor you know what i'm gonna do now
i'm gonna start telling my lps hey you
know what let's just take out those
three bad investments i'm a great
investor like what
like it's like if you went to school and
on the report card they calculated your
gpa and you said ah those two classes i
failed
don't take those out
plus student
like this is insane and the funniest
part is that we literally have people in
suits ties and cologne that go up on
national television stand there at the
podium trying to look all serious while
they have the media in front of them
like well if you take out the beef pork
and poultry then the grocery prices
haven't actually increased that much
what
what is going on
why is nobody calling nonsense why is
nobody stand up and say uh stupid
question but aren't beef and poultry
groceries
why would they not be included in the
grocery price index
yeah i bought some beef the other day it
was expensive of course it's expensive
of course
the thing it has exploded
in price
but the whole point is they're
continuing to manipulate the data just
like you know that some companies this
idea of shrink flation so they they keep
the price the same but they actually
give you less of the good so if you
think of it like think of like a bag of
chips if they used to fill it up 80 with
chips 20 with air now all of a sudden
maybe they fill it up with 60 chips 40
air but the price stayed the same and so
what they'll say is oh we haven't
increased our prices
true
but you also are giving people less of
the good and therefore that is a form of
inflation as well and so you can have
true inflation you can have shrink
flation but now what ends up happening
is you get manipulation of data and you
see this in the jobs reports you see
this and all kinds of stuff remember
there are five plus million people in
this country that say that they can't
work because of covet
we still haven't figured out what that
qua what qualifies you for that and so
this is another example where
the data is overwhelming
inflation the cpi number is the highest
that it has been in 13 years
core inflation is as high as it's been
in 30 years and we have people who are
specifically
mandated to look after the economy
the national economic council
this is not some you know idiot on the
internet who
pulled up a spreadsheet and is trying to
manipulate data so you can win a twitter
war right it's not somebody who's
talking about it in a newsletter because
they're trying to drive more clicks to
their newsletter this is the national
economic council is telling you
that grocery prices if you take out the
things that have increased in price
are more in line with historical norms
what is going on
this makes
zero sense
and the reason is because if they
actually tell the truth
it's really really alarming remember the
bottom half
of the country
food is one of their greatest expenses
they spend an inordinate amount of their
monthly revenue their monthly income on
food so when grocery prices explode
rich people aren't nearly as affected
they're less sensitive to increasing
food prices they know whether the beef
is two dollars
or four dollars
they can afford it
they don't care i don't know this is the
last time we're having beef
it was expensive
okay just keep going keep going
the people
at the bottom
of the financial totem pole
they can't afford it
and so
this isn't like they're saying oh super
exotic almond milk has gone up in price
they're not saying oh if you go and you
get the organic vegan
whatever
meat
it's gone up in price
they're not saying oh if you go and you
get the
sour dough
you know whatever bread it's gone up in
price they're literally saying beef pork
and poultry like a staple food in
everyone's diet
this isn't some weird thing that
hipsters in brooklyn are buying it's not
something that your grandma buys because
she bought it 70 years ago right no it's
something that every single american
eats almost every single day beef pork
and poultry
have gone up in price and they want to
not include in grocery prices
stupid the root of the problem to me is
they know exactly what they're doing and
they're going to continue to do it until
someone either stops them or calls them
out on it enough to where everyone
realizes it and almost revolts to a
sense i mean like they're manipulating
the numbers in ridiculous manners
and i'm i'm frankly just tired of
hearing them manipulate the numbers i
just i can't even watch it anymore it's
comical we're laughing as we're talking
about the topic because
we know that they're manipulating the
numbers and we know that people are
actually getting hurt because of this
and this is why like you should do your
own research and you should actually
read what they are excluding what
they're including because a headline
would be grocery prices haven't gone up
at all that's the problem even when you
do the research they hide the numbers so
well sometimes you can't even find the
actual number yeah you're like oh yeah
just grocery prices are all right
and then you're like oh wait they took
out [ __ ] meat poultry yeah
no it's crazy real quick real quick
we're gonna pull up uh this chart that i
am setting the mat right now
uh i we should have had this earlier but
it's okay compared to february 2020 the
price of beef and veal
is up 13
i told you
then the price
before the pandemic in june so from
february 2020 to june 2021 the price of
beef is up double digits
it's up more than 2x with cpi what do
you think is causing that supply chain
issues um
just regular just uh absolutely
everything
so there are look here's the chart real
quick let's look at the numbers and then
we'll talk about why so since february
2020 this was in june
the percent change
beef
is up
13
pork
up more than 10 percent
poultry up nearly 10 percent
double digit increases
for staple items in every single
person's diet
cakes
up four percent
the cakes are
up bread up more than the two percent
inflation target every single item
that's listed here beef veal pork
poultry fish seafood cakes cupcakes
cookies bread fresh biscuits rolls
muffins fruits and vegetables everything
is up more than the fed's two percent
inflation target
everything do you think that people
would have been in the street protesting
if this had happened without the
government sending checks and printing
more money
here's the scary part is i actually
think americans are super soft
and what i think would end up happening
is we we've moved to this world of
complacency where people would rather
say
oh i'll just change my diet i'll go do
something no way
absolutely
absolutely you're not getting the
carnivores out here becoming vegan no
not vegan but what they're going to do
is they're going to buy less meat or
they'll change their diet they'll start
buying other types of food that haven't
exploded in price because ultimately
remember
egypt right for those that uh paid
attention back in i think it was 2011
2012. the egyptian uh
revolt or or the demonstrations in
protest there was definitely some social
media coordination etc but a lot of it
stemmed from food prices exploded
if you can't afford food
you and your family will go hungry and
so it wasn't just that 10 increase the
food prices exploded right in each but i
forget exactly what the numbers were but
it drastically increased and so there's
an old saying uh that i'm going to
paraphrase because i can't remember who
said it but basically like if you want
to see what man is capable of don't feed
them for 72 hours yeah
right this stuff makes me sad there's an
element of
at some point a human being's body goes
into survival mode and says i can't i
have no food my family has no food and
so what do people do they go into the
streets there's violence there's all
this bad stuff i'm not suggesting that's
gonna happen in the united states
because i don't think that we've seen
enough of a food price increase to
actually get people super worked up but
the fact that people are literally
listening to the national economic
council say oh poultry beef you know
just pull that out of there and no
problem
and we don't have 20 reporters
immediately calling [ __ ] on it
it's crazy to me that's crazy to me
i'm no longer convinced supply chain
issue based off that chart it's going
back up to where it was in uh what march
and april of 2020 2020 yeah
so there's definitely some supply chains
the hard part is you can't quantify what
is due to the supply chain issues what's
due to
raising uh labor costs or rising labor
costs and what is due to just pure
inflation i mean look at beef and field
dude
it's crazy you know what that looks like
it looks like the fed's balance sheet
just popping off the screen except
theirs doesn't come down
so the
idea of uh
oh my god the price of beef from june
2021 over may so from may to june in a
month-over-month growth guess what the
increase in beef prices was 10 5
4.5
from may of 2021 to june of 2020 30 days
31 days four and a half percent increase
in beef
insane
and so when you start to look at this uh
eggs up three percent pork 3.1 ham 3.1
it's pretty crazy
i'm literally reading an article right
now and they explicitly caught compared
to a year ago however the price of beef
was down 2.8
right because if we pulled the char one
last time if you actually look at
the
peak of beef last year that's why in may
it hits 16 percentage that's another way
that i've seen people manipulate the
numbers in the last year or so it's like
well compared to last year
like when everything was inflated
and there was no toilet paper at the
grocery store yeah but on an absolute
basis it's up a ton
i mean it's just
look you know at this point um
we can talk about this till we're blue
in the face
there is inflation
and we can argue all day long is beef's
inflation 10 or 12 percent it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it's up a lot
from where it was last year and so is
every other consumer good
and because of that
if you're sitting here you have to worry
about two things
as a consumer and as an investor as a
consumer
don't buy the things that are super
expensive
start to understand what is going up in
price
use cars exploding in value certain
foods exploding in value if you are
trying to live within your means if
you're trying to spend less than you
make get out of debt do all kind of the
traditional personal finance
mechanisms
don't buy the things that you know are
going up in price go find alternatives
go find the things that still allow you
to do what you want to do but they don't
require you to pay in or inordinate
increases in price
as an investor
understand that the macro structure of
the market is that the dollar is being
aggressively devalued 38 of us dollars
in circulation were created in the last
18 months
you can either suffer at the hands of
that inflation and debasement of the
currency or you can be a beneficiary of
it and it comes down to one thing
education
do you know how the system works and if
you do are you invested because everyone
who's invested is getting hilariously
rich right now
stocks real estate crypto etc not bonds
or gold but everything else
is just going up in price the stock
market hits an all-time high every day
it's literally like a new rule in the
stock market market open all-time high
market open all-time high has to happen
crypto continues to go up in price
and so when you look at this stuff you
either suffer at the hands of the
inflation or you end up benefiting from
it that's the decision that you have to
make and it all comes down to education
and then action you can choose not to
act and you'll continue to suffer or you
can choose to actually put yourself in a
better position it's pretty simple
right
yeah also i was wondering if this
actually is helping these startups and
possible foods and beyond meat
which are fake meat companies
um and yeah it says they're you know
battling to achieve price parity with
real meat
it's like at this point
it might be cheaper to eat well
traditionally that stuff was more
expensive right right the p the reason
people paid for it was because it was
supposedly better for you and healthier
for you um but that's absolutely yeah
and look i don't know the size beyond it
but at some point people are just gonna
buy it because it's cheap right which is
crazy
do we think that the prices come down
later no no i i thought about that
didn't even bring it up because i was
like there's just no way
so we just end up with well to be honest
as a store owner why would you bring the
prices back down you just make more
money there's no as a store owner or an
operator or any type of business there's
no point for you bringing the prices
down because you already realize that
your customer is willing to pay that
price for that item basically there's no
price sensitivity you're still buying it
yeah why would you you already look and
and there is a kind of balance between
hey we sell less of them because they're
more expensive and all that stuff right
which is why the cost of goods on some
companies they try to bring down
their margins and the cost of their
items but as like a grocery store people
are always going to go to the girls i
love grocery stores because they're
they're recession-proof you think so
yeah
because you cause you have to you have
to buy groceries but i think for 72
hours you go mad
yeah but i think you reach a point where
it's so expensive that it's unrealistic
for what you're making right so it's
like i cannot even afford half the
groceries i used to afford before so and
then there's social media and people are
saying competition will bring the
grocery or any prices down right which
is true but ultimately the consumer is
going to decide and it and they really
decide on is it convenient is it cheap
and those are going to be the deciding
factors to who wins uh who gets your
business
uh two things from the comments real
quick i think it's lino said uh meat has
decreased in price compared to bitcoin
so if you denominate
in dollars it's exploded if you
denominate beef in bitcoin it goes down
perfect example of the difference
between the two currencies one your
purchasing power decreases over time
everything gets more expensive the other
your purchasing power increases over
time and everything gets less expensive
so great point there second is
father finger
in all caps
talking that smack in the comments said
don't buy the expensive stuff dot dot
dot he said from the starbucks cup
listen that was a gift
yeah somebody somebody got that for me
because i was so exhausted
it was convenient it was very convenient
i don't buy starbucks somebody else buys
it
i got no loyalty when it comes to
businesses
starbucks duncan your local coffee shop
i don't care whatever is the most
convenient and the cheapest i'm gonna go
too
you don't have any loyalty at all no i
loyalty but not to like a business like
that
i actually prefer to support the local
businesses over the giant chains but hey
look if it's convenient and it's cheaper
i'm gonna go to the big conglomerates
well i know that there's one
uh food sector that you have loyalty to
two brands
beer
what's the go-to beer
uh no free advertising
[Laughter]
right but like there are some food
sectors where i think people have
loyalty at a much higher degree than
like coffee okay fine if i'm somewhere
and there's one on the corner i need
coffee i'll go there very rarely will
you see people go completely out of
their way to go to a different coffee
shop some people will but not everybody
yeah but that's kind of my point right
is if there's a if there's a coffee shop
right on your corner versus two blocks
away you're more likely to go to the
coffee shop right on your corner even if
it's 10 more for the price of the coffee
it depends i think well does plenty
disagree it depends how much you think
your time's worth and the convenience of
walking two blocks and how much money
you're willing to spend on a cup of
coffee i mean
john and i are willing to spend whatever
for a good cup of joe good cup of jelly
anthony you're drinking starbucks right
now
what's wrong with that is that cheap
coffee all right is that cheap coffee no
we're going to settle a debate real
quick right now in the comments before
we bring on ricky williams i need you
guys to do two things i need to smash
the like button and then i want you guys
to put in the comments do you prefer
starbucks or dunkin donuts which one is
better starbucks or dunkin donuts hurry
up and then we will go and joe's in the
chat he said cup of joe
joe said that yeah yeah joe yeah hey joe
just so you know you got fired today
because you weren't watching earlier
let's see starbucks dunkin donuts
starbucks dunkin
phil
tim hortons
starbucks tims
krispy kreme
all right
real quick before we bring ricky
williams on here's what i need you guys
to do we got to get to a thousand likes
let's go smash the like button real
quick hit the thumbs up so more people
see this on youtube and then we're gonna
bring ricky we're i'm gonna go check
them in real quick hit the like button
let's go let me go check them in and
make sure the audio video is good and
then we'll be right back with the legend
ricky williams
[Music]
the best business show is exactly that
it's the best why because it's the show
that me joe and john wish that we had
when we were learning
now we've got the best partner which is
so fun so far is one of those platforms
that just hits different why sofi is
basically a super app it does everything
from allowing you to have budgeting and
saving tools to helping you refinance
student loans and they help you invest
in everything from etfs to individual
stocks pre-ipo companies and
cryptocurrencies use the link below or
go to
sofi.com
to sign up for a sofi active invest
account and you can win up to a thousand
dollars
when you want anything to help you
create a better financial life sofi
likely can do it if you're looking for a
platform where you can go and do all in
one sofa is that place we're really
excited to partner with sofi on this
because we think they've built an
amazing product and we think that the
product and features that they have will
help simplify the lives of our audience
go check them out today at sofi.com
and let us know what you think sofi.com
that's where we'll be
[Music]
all right all right we are back
we have ricky williams with us let's
bring him up real quick
ricky how you doing
how are you doing we're doing uh we're
doing fantastic man thank you so much
for uh for taking the time to do this um
i think let's just jump in first with uh
what have you been up to since uh since
you left the league
i've been up to a lot of different
things you know
like a lot of retired football players
we get into entrepreneurship and so
i started a couple of companies and
i'm really enjoying it you know a lot of
retired players talk about how difficult
it is once they retired i have to start
over but uh i really enjoyed the the
growing and the learning process
talk to us a little bit about some of
the companies that you've started or
like you know how do you think through
you have so many opportunities uh either
people bring to you or ideas that you
have what's the process like in terms of
vetting those and then deciding hey this
is the company that uh that i want to go
ahead and start
you know it really is a
i did a lot of research you know i think
what happens after football
is we've or any any professional athlete
is we've dedicated so much of our life
to becoming really good at something
it's like okay what's next and i was
fortunate enough
to have retired twice i retired in 2004
took a year off traveled around the
world
and that was a golden opportunity for me
to really get to know and understand
myself and one of the things
i found during that year off was
astrology another thing was i started
studying herbalism and alternative
medicine and so i came back to the nfl
and played another six years
i was developing these these talents and
these skills so when i left the nfl i i
had
already started to build another skill
set and so it was really about honing
those skills and so one of the companies
is an astrological relationship app
helping people understand themselves and
the people in their lives using
astrology and the other one is a
cannabis brand a cannabis wellness brand
well i take what i know about herbs and
take what i know about cannabis and i
make formulas to help people feel better
um before we talk about the cannabis
company and then we're gonna get into
some of the nft stuff you're doing as
well uh i gotta ask you when i when i
heard that you were coming on the show i
was like oh my god i've got one question
for ricky williams there's the famous
story of the reporter who found you in
australia and you were at like this i
think he described as a jungle paradise
just tell us kind of like where were you
and what was that experience like like
the way it's described in the article i
remember reading a couple years ago
being like man it sounds like ricky
williams just enjoys life and like that
seems like an awesome way to live
you know yeah
for me not for everyone you know but for
me at that time in my life it's exactly
what it was exactly what i needed so
it's a town uh it's popular in australia
a town called byron bay and it is it is
this jungle paradise it's right on the
water it's on the ocean but it's also
got some tropical rainforest there and
it was a really special time in my life
yeah it was awesome
[Laughter]
this smile on your face makes me think
that you just have a bunch of great
memories from it so my brothers and i
maybe we need to uh we need to go check
it out so tell us about the cannabis
brand that you have
i think you said it's a cannabis
lifestyle brand and so um you know
what's the name of it and how did you
guys uh kind of come up with all this
i actually have two there's two two
cannabis brands one i started 2018 one
we're launching this this fall 2018 when
i stepped into the cannabis space i
really wanted to lead with medicinal
cannabis and again my background as an
herbalist and so
i created formulas that we have formulas
to treat people's headaches anxiety
sleep things that everyone suffers from
and a big part of that was you know
i think everyone you know talks about
the recreational
aspects of cannabis but i think not a
lot of people talk about how it actually
helps us feel better and what we're
launching this fall as we're calling it
the heisman
and it really is about bringing sports
and cannabis together and
you know my story if people know
uh cannabis and sports were something
that that were separated i was punished
for for using cannabis and now that the
world is changing and people are
starting to open up their minds more
it's time it's time to bring cannabis
and sports together and the main
question i'm trying to get people to ask
is instead of looking at
the athletes who inspire us in punishing
them for using cannabis maybe we should
think hey if these guys are inspiring us
and they're using cannabis maybe they're
on to something and starting to ask
us
why we use cannabis what we use it for
and how it helps us in our lives
what's fascinating to me i think about
your story is uh obviously everyone knew
that uh it was not allowed to use
cannabis right but there was something
that you personally found um kind of
enjoyable about it and uh and obviously
use the cannabis there's tons of these
like viral clips and stuff from everyone
every talking head in the sports world
talking about when it was all going on
what was kind of your thought process
when all of that was happening right so
when you were being punished etc there's
an element in my mind of when you look
at like criminal justice reform right uh
we lock people away in a cage for
smoking a plant right like it it's
insane and for you there was a different
punishment because of the profession
that you had chosen but like what's
going through your mind when all that's
playing out but you're like look you
know it's cannabis it's not like you're
uh you know dealing drugs or doing
anything like you know kind of crazy to
hurt other people it's just something
that you personally enjoy doing
yeah i guess
you know it's something that i think
everyone goes through right i think we
all have things that we know
feel good to us and and help us feel
better
and there's things that we're told we're
not supposed to do and sometimes those
things collide and there's this inner
struggle
and i think at the end of the day it's
it's a positive thing because you know
what i found is if i truly want to be
happy i have to learn to listen to my
heart and brave the consequences uh and
and that's worked out
and sometimes you know we're ahead of
our time and and we have to break the
consequences a little bit longer but as
things are starting to change and turn
around and people are starting to see
uh maybe i was on to something it's you
know it feels really good
uh last question on this and we'll talk
about the nft work is uh do you think
that the nfl and college football the
ncaa uh both of them should legalize the
use of marijuana for the athletes
well you know i think legalizing it i
mean that that's really up to the to the
government but i definitely think these
leaks should stop punishing athletes and
i think also should start providing
cannabis to the athletes
so you think the nfl and the ncaa should
be giving weed to the players
well they're giving they're giving them
pain pills um
yeah so i think why not
yeah it's a very unique uh perspective
and i think when people hear kind of at
a high level there's like a shock value
to it like what do you mean like that
sounds crazy but when you it's not it's
not it's not unique that this is the
whole issue is we we lie to ourselves
that it's unique you know this is what i
this is what i learned this is what i
this is the truth okay is that when i
was going through everything with the
nfl you know everybody was silent nobody
stood up no one said anything you know
and what i found out is a large majority
of those people smoke too and so it's
it's really just a bunch of hypocrisy
and so
yeah i
feel like the best thing that i've done
is i've made it a little bit safer to be
honest about cannabis use and i think
that's a positive thing
there's a lot of people who are very
appreciative uh to you for for doing
that i think that uh you've definitely
pioneered a bunch there talk to me about
the the nfts that uh that you're
launching and kind of how this came
together
yeah well it it's really interesting you
know i get that i feel as i get older i
really depend on on younger people to
to bring me new information and new new
technology and so the university of
texas last year decided to change the
name of the football field to the
campbell williams field after earl
campbell and myself and
because of covid last year there wasn't
really a chance to sell it and for the
first first week this year um they said
they're going to celebrate it and so
i was called up by by christian campbell
uh earl's son
and he asked if i was interested in
creating some enemies for the event and
you know i feel like an old guy i was
like i've heard about these nft things
and so he sent me a bunch of information
and i started to do my research and i
was really just blown away
uh mainly at the opportunity it gives
for for artists
um i've always felt like in my heart i'm
i'm an artist and so i've always related
to artists and i
and i see the opportunities that they're
getting and most importantly i see how
communities are being built around nfts
and so i said i said whatever i can do
to be a part of this let's do it and and
then as we got into it more i saw it was
a great way to raise money uh to
increase the diversity at the university
of texas and so just a lot of opera
opportunities coming out of this one has
just been exciting but especially
all the learning i'm doing
what is uh kind of the feeling like to
go back to the university of texas and
have your name on the stadium like
that's gotta be a pretty cool uh
experience
oh can you hear us
yeah i can hear you uh what what was the
experience like now that your name's on
the stadium at texas it's gonna be
pretty cool like how does that feel to
know that uh the stadium is named after
you
know it's um
when we talked about it last year it was
it was you know it was a cool idea but
to actually be on the field and to see
you know right now there are these huge
pictures of earl and myself
on on the scoreboard and to know that
this season every team every football
player that comes into that stadium to
play football is gonna is gonna know
about earl and myself it's just a great
honor and considering the earlier part
of this conversation
you know i think it's really a great
example to young people all over the
place that it's okay to be yourself you
know that
sometimes you're gonna stumble and fall
but if you just stay true to yourself
and you keep going they'll name a field
after you so
i think it's it's a wonderful story
awesome i've got my brother john here
he's got a question for you
yeah ricky what's up uh juan just thank
you for doing this and congratulations
on all your success both on and off the
field i love how you describe yourself
as an artist a herbalist your your
ability your inventor you're super super
smart guy um but i'm curious about how
how do you split your time now like you
seem to be focused on so many different
things what what is exciting to you in
the future like what are you building on
what are you spending most of your time
looking at
well
so my mind is always
filtering everything through an
astrological lids you know uh i'm a
a bunch of stuff but i think underneath
i'm a philosopher and so what i love
about astrology is it's a it's a
framework that allows me to understand
the world and help it make sense and so
creating and thinking about more ways to
make this kind this astrological
information astrological worldview more
accessible to people um that's what i'm
passionate about and that's what i'm
thinking about all the time and what i'm
thinking about now you know after this
weekend is how to incorporate nfts into
everything i know about astrology and i
know there's that's a rich rich feel
that i'm excited to keep diving deeper
into
ricky what is the name of the nft work
that you're doing or where can we send
people to uh to find out more about it
um so you can send them to
vybehouse.com
okay and
yeah it's all the information experience
is awesome man
uh and so what people basically they'll
get super bowl tickets vip party uh
dinner with earl etc it's pretty cool
yeah and they get to talk astrology with
me
[Laughter]
all right last question i got for you
before we let you go uh he doesn't know
i'm gonna ask you this but uh one of the
folks that we've gotten to know and are
huge fans of we're big new york giants
fans uh saquon barkley obviously the
best running back in the nfl gonna be a
super bowl champion etc uh what would be
your advice to him uh as he uh continues
to compete on the field but also off the
field as he starts looking more at like
business and investing right you were
this kind of legendary running back that
now has transitioned and spent a bunch
of time investing and building companies
what advice do you have for somebody
who's kind of earlier in their career
and appears to be following a summer
trajectory to you
well yeah so i think one of the things
that i've realized about
being a professional athlete and aside
from the sports and aside from what we
do on the field we have access access to
people people want to be around us they
want to offer us things they want to
give us things and so i i tell them use
that you know is is be curious right now
you know when you're young you're not
supposed to have it figured out it's a
great time to ask questions and so seek
uh seek mentors really think about what
he wants to do in the future and
surround himself with people that are
that are doing it now yeah that's great
advice um where do you want us to uh to
send folks so we've got the nft is there
anywhere else you want people to follow
you on twitter or do anything else uh
yeah online on twitter it's uh at rick
laureate uh
that's a great name man
yeah
yeah i got i got big plans um
and on instagram is at williams i don't
know how i got it but uh but i got it
and the brand is heisman dot co
uh check us out
awesome man well listen thank you so
much for taking the time to do this
today the the nft experience that you
guys are building is pretty cool and as
my brother said congrats on on the
naming of the stadium it uh it's one of
those things where uh a bunch of folks
my age we grew up and we were watching
you play and now to kind of see you get
celebrated for all the uh the hard work
you put in is pretty cool so uh good
luck on all the business ventures and
we'll have to do this again in the
future as you can continue progressing
yeah my pleasure thank you guys all
right sounds good buddy talk soon
all right
legend
he he's a beast
just
like it depends on how old you are
ricky williams is a legend and to be
able to uh balance
star nfl player
philosopher
astrology expert
cannabis connoisseur
herbalist well that's one of the things
multifaceted people have the
misconception about athletes is like oh
they only play football like you can see
in in him like he's excited about so
many different things uh and it i'm
really excited to see what he does in
the future and obviously he's already
accomplished a ton hall of famer
somebody's asking he should be a hall of
famer yeah
isn't he already in the whole family i
don't think he's in the hall of fame
he's not yet i don't think he should be
he should he's in my hall of fame he was
stiff-arming people and how about being
a heisman trophy winner and then
starting a company name it heisman yeah
like you you're uh you're a
goat
all right we're gonna bring dan tapario
onto the show here in a sec i need to go
check his audio and video he recently
raised
750 million dollars 750 million dollars
to deploy into bitcoin ether crypto
industry we will be right back with him
don't go anywhere make sure you smash
the like button he's not a herbalist but
he's got some cool things to talk about
[Music]
wait don't skip this ad think of it as
an investment because with sofi's
all-in-one platform you can save spend
earn borrow and invest that's right sofi
has a super app you can buy stocks and
etfs trade crypto or open an automated
portfolio all with no account minimums
and zero commission on trades use the
link below or go to sofi.com
to sign up for a sofi active invest
account and you can win up to a thousand
dollars plus members now have access to
upcoming ipos before they begin trading
on an exchange which is really
especially cool for retail investors and
with sofi social investing you can
follow other members and see what
they're investing in including me
seriously to see how i'm investing just
search anthony pompliano in the sofi app
start investing today with sofi at
sofi.com pomp thanks again to sofi for
sponsoring this episode and make sure
you go to sofi.com to sign up today
[Music]
[Music]
we're back
let's bring dan up let's just start here
i'm gonna give him the opportunity to
roast me fine
dad what's up man
how you been i'm great tappy arrow is
that how i say it
that's how you say it you said it
correctly many times before so i don't
know what what got into i said his name
wrong one time and as soon as i get on
zoom he starts roasting me for saying
they're wrong well look i i know you
have problems with with names ending in
oh but uh you know this is an easy one
i hear you i hear you how are you
good good i mean i've been
busy as can be uh
you know we've sort of had even limited
uh interactions it's just been a
whirlwind the last four or five months
and
i've been off twitter
um i mean on but not as much as before
and you know not as uh you know
deeply ingrained in sort of the the
markets um you know as we built out the
uh the holdings of 10t
talk to us about 10t and what the kind
of original idea was and then walk us
through uh this 750 million dollar
fundraiser across the various vehicles
yeah um you know the idea originally was
to build a broad sort of macro sector
exposure
um to the digit to the growth in the
digital asset ecosystem so you know as
you know i'm a pretty hardcore bitcoiner
but i also think there is a world where
there are lots of things growing up in
the overall ecosystem
lots of great businesses uh that have
grown up and you know i'm not my
background is not as a venture
capitalist so i don't have a specialty
in you know
trying to figure out you know which code
is better and you know which chain is
going to work for whatever it is and so
i said to myself look i there's a
there's a lot going on in this um in the
private equity uh world in the digital
asset ecosystem there are a lot of
companies that are a lot larger
than people understand and you know i'd
like to get that kind of exposure for my
own uh personal portfolio and dtap
capital and so
um went about the idea of constructing
this portfolio of 10 to 15
uh businesses operating in the space
again not involved with the
cryptocurrencies or you know the
protocols or tokens or anything else
except for
the equity in these businesses
and i did that largely because um i
wanted i wanted to build something that
was very easy for outsiders to
understand for
you know as we say people in the legacy
world or the boomer crowd or just people
over 50 who have a really hard time
uh understanding what's going on here
and are not comfortable uh with direct
exposure in the underlying
cryptocurrencies especially you know i
think the volatility um is a problem and
also
uh you know what are the exact
fundamentals that are driving these
things it's just it's just a lot to
comprehend you know if you've had
success and you've been in the
traditional investment world for 30
years it's just not that easy to make a
transition and so i i said listen i'm
building this portfolio for myself and
this is how i would like it um to look
um and we just went out built a team
went out
and spoke to people in my network and
friends of mine and people from my
background
and said look this is this is what the
portfolio broadly is going to look like
and what we did is we broke it down into
three buckets there's digital asset
ecosystem gateways next gen financial
services businesses and blockchain
infrastructure companies and basically
we have three to four uh companies in
each bucket
and the idea really is to hold them for
five six seven years
and i think we're going to get multiples
appreciation you saw in the press
release some of the businesses that
we've all that we all already own and i
i know you're familiar with all of them
and you're you're an investor yourself
and actually a few of them
um
talk to me about when you went out to
raise the money so you've got a very
unique position in that for 25 years
you've invested across markets you've
started previous businesses before
in different sectors
you've worked with or for
some of the best global macro investors
in the world
and so you've got kind of a very unique
uh network and and uh the trust of a lot
of people and you've done great work
with it with a bunch of people that are
well respected in traditional finance
when you went out to have those
conversations what was the reaction from
whether it was you know the billionaire
friends or from these like institutional
allocators
yeah i mean
it's funny
i always say this it sort of broke down
like almost
you know according to age uh you know if
i met somebody who was an investor let's
say in their 30s they were super
interested but you know usually writing
smaller
checks and
you know
meeting guys sort of in their 60s or
later very tough
um but of course you know they're
um you know they're managing most of the
money so
it's sort of we have a nice
cross-section yes a lot of guys from my
background uh all the lps more or less
are
friends or people from my network as you
said
i think people
um i
i think people who were interested in
the space
but just didn't have exposure and were
looking for ways to get exposure
um those are the people who really
were excited by the idea because look
the investment team and i we write these
50 page investment memos that take weeks
if not months sometimes um behind each
of the investments and so i can say
listen the fund is putting in
and this is how we really got to the 750
you know i would say the fund itself
which is around 390 million you know the
fund is investing let's say 40 million
dollars into this business and then i
would say
you know here's our research this is why
and you know
there's co-invest if you're interested
and so what's happened is is because
quite a few of the lps are from the
money management business they're either
retired or still in the game they they
read the 50-page investment memo and
then they you know they make a decision
for themselves and so you know in some
cases you have guys who you know put
let's say a million dollars into the
fund but then all of a sudden they're
asking for 5 million of co-invest or 10
million um it's because they they have
quite a lot of firepower
and uh you know i think they're happy
uh to have the general exposure in the
fun but they're also experienced enough
to want to really leverage up
when they see the opportunity and
you know i would say the skill we have
really is in explaining something very
clearly and you know i that that's sort
of the one skill that i developed
uh over 25 years uh not only you know
managing my own portfolio and portfolios
you know at the funds where i worked at
but you know
always sort of being very working very
closely with the head of those funds and
being able to explain yourself clearly
simply
um you know and to be able to explain a
subject that is foreign
um
you know and and to put it in terms that
people will understand
i think has been the reason why
we've grown so quickly and it's sort of
way beyond my expectations
um because the co-invest uh vehicles all
add up to about another
you know call it 300 million or so so
uh actually i think it's it's actually
more it's i think it's closer to 350
uh in in co-invest vehicles and i don't
think we
you know we've allocated about
remarkably 80 percent of the fund money
and again we really just launched at the
end of january so i mean it's been as i
said drinking from a fire hose
when you think about the um i'll just
call them kind of billionaire wall
street asset management crowd uh and the
institutional investor crowd i think
that you guys had a a public pension
also participate that was publicly named
talk to me about the difference in
conversations between the individuals
that yes they are very wealthy yes they
operate in some form or fashion like an
institution to some degree but the
institutions that you actually have
participating what was the difference in
conversation there
yeah i mean it's sort of interesting um
yeah i think it was it was released in
the bloomberg article it is state of
michigan their pension fund uh merce
they
uh they invested a considerable amount
and i think they were looking for a way
to get exposure
um
you know i don't think they own a
bitcoin or can and but you know they're
smart people they wanted to get exposure
to the sector broadly but weren't really
interested in taking on the risk of
early stage investments and you know the
minimum size and
market value of companies we look at is
500 but of the 11 businesses we we own
um
you know only
uh nine of them are over a billion
dollars in market valuation only two are
sort of between 500 and a billion and so
you know they didn't
you know they're those types of
businesses are also de-risked
um they don't have the same type of
business risk look they're not going to
go up 100x like uh solana or you know
some of these other things that have
moved uh 100 200 x or whatever it is you
know we we think some of the businesses
can go up five to ten times in the next
uh five six seven eight years
and for a big fund like that um
you know they can put a lot of money to
work in bigger names
um but it also helped that a very close
friend of mine
had
taken an investment from them a friend
of mine about 15 years
you know knew them very very well
and he of course spoke on our behalf
to them i did not reach out to them i
didn't know them beforehand
um but honestly i was told that um you
know they turned around within a few
weeks to make the investment
uh i was told that like never before has
a pension fund turned around that
quickly i i don't i'm not you know i
i've never really raised a lot of money
um i'd always worked for funds that had
more capital than they knew what to do
with so
i was never on any sort of fundraising
circuit uh you know where i met pension
funds or whatever it was so it was
really again as i described before
there are institutional players out
there from the legacy world they just
don't know how to access it and play it
in a way that they're comfortable with
and so the fund is somewhat structured
you know based on my own personal
parameters what i wanted for my own
portfolio but also you know with
you know keeping in mind of course what
other institutional type you know um and
you know
uh more institutional type investors uh
want and are comfortable with we also
have a a foundation uh an la based
foundation
but you know they're you know multiple
billion dollar foundation but they're
very uh savvy they you know they've been
long actually bitcoin i think and
ethereum for quite a while
and they have a few venture investments
but just not
it's just there's too much risk there
they don't you know they don't want a
black or red option and i think that
that just means that you know the
typical vc i guess you know makes ten
investments and nine go to zero and and
and one ends up being google and the
fund returns you know a zillion percent
that's sort of i don't know i'm sort of
uncomfortable with that strategy even
though it's worked brilliantly and in
this space the vcs have had huge returns
um but there's only so much an investor
can have even if he likes that strategy
in a vc bucket
and so
um
you know 10t which only invests in the
mid to late stage companies in the space
uh is sort of a as i call it more of a
broad sector bet uh you could call it uh
like in a sense you could think of us as
building an index of the future i mean i
think if you look at the companies we've
bought i think
look within five years most of them will
probably be public um you know some of
them could be in the s p 500
uh you know if they weren't in crypto
you know some of them are making
hundreds of millions of dollars of
revenue they'd already be public and in
the s p so
um
but i think that's a little bit of an
advantage for us
that the growth equity guys who would
normally
play in this space
um you know except for you know the
tigers and co2s and they'll come in and
write one-off checks and you know they
can do whatever they like but
most of the growth equity space they're
not that comfortable with currency or
with macro
and this really is a macro bet and we're
using the private equity structure
to take a long-term view
because i think the one thing that kills
you in this space
is you know the short term view i think
no one knows what's going to happen on a
three month or five month view or even
necessarily on a one year view but
on a five year view three to five years
you have a very
high degree of conviction
and as you know i mean since we started
talking almost two years ago
um you know in the middle of 19
i've had a very strong view about how
this world was developing and where
bitcoin prices were headed
um you know and i remember that that uh
that interview we did about gold and
bitcoin
um
you know i think
uh
you know i still am a believer in
physical gold and that's a conversation
for another day
um i've got lots of exposures in my
portfolio i know pomp i know you're 100
long bitcoin in your portfolio but
for us you know guys a little bit older
we're not quite a 100 percent um you
know and and try to have a few different
types of exposures
um
but uh
you know i think that this is a
differentiated enough
expression of an investment
of view
that it is attractive um you know for
that institutional but but who's
interested right the guys who say to me
there were many guys who just said it's
ponzi we don't believe in this no thank
you and i was like okay it was very easy
conversations because we were rejected
right away
uh or
they had been thinking about it right
and so those people we try to help and
we try to educate and we give them
things to read uh we send them some of
your podcasts believe it or not
um you know so
you know as you know there's a lot of
educating to do in this space
when you think about bitcoin let's start
there uh where do you think bitcoin goes
from a price standpoint this year are
you a believer in this like super cycle
theory are you more a believer that you
know we kind of just go sideways how do
you think about bitcoin through the end
of the year
well you know i just said it's almost
pointless to have a three to four month
view but i know that's what you know
sort of people look at it look i was in
the hedge fund business and i had marks
every day and every week and
liquidity every month i mean i lived
that for you know 25 years you said i
just think that you know this is an
asset that's returned 250 annualized
over the last 11 years it's the greatest
return of any asset in the history of
the world i mean probably going back to
caveman times um so
i
don't think i mean i really am a hodler
i don't think you mess around with that
i i always thought and i've said
probably even a year ago i think that we
we're going to get to around a trillion
dollar market valuation and then we
would consolidate
and that's sort of where we've done i
mean in my world view
forty thousand bitcoin fifty thousand
six hundred it's all basically around
the same price
um i think we could still get to 100
uh by the end of the year i
you know we might need some macro things
to happen i think that's more likely
sort of within six to 12 months
um
but
you know and i i think i've said this on
our our last interview and i even two
years ago that three four five hundred
thousand which would put the market
value at call it you know five six
trillion dollars
that was the first stop for me um you
know and i just simply
you know i've talked about this a lot
but it just in my mind
i think okay bitcoin you know the most
decentralized most secure network in the
history of the world the potential sort
of value protocol for the entire
internet okay
and it's worth a trillion dollars which
is roughly half of amazon which is just
one company
so to me
i look at i think you know how much
would it cost even a company to to try
to build the bitcoin network
from scratch i mean it's trillions and
trillions of dollars so you know five
trillion dollar market value is a
is a comfortable estimate that i am very
comfortable with in fact i called the
fund we called the fund 10t now 10t
stands for 10 trillion and what is that
well the market value okay when we
started thinking about this idea in 1920
i said the value of bitcoin ethereum all
the cryptocurrency and all the equity
in the space okay was around 300 billion
and i said well
i think we can go from 300 billion to 10
trillion in 10 years and so that's sort
of our mantra 10 t in 10 years but the
problem is we're at 3 trillion now
so
like we're a chip shot away from 10
trillion in 10 years i mean we we just
launched really in in january
and
we're already at 3t
so
you know the biggest mistake i made with
all of this my the was i've
underestimated the
exponentiality of the growth in the
space
um it just it's it's sort of not
anything that the mind can comprehend
and last thing i'd say on this though is
that what i was just looking at the
teaser for the fun that we wrote a year
ago
there were 20 businesses that we
identified with over a billion dollar
market valuation
today
there are 70. just think about that
70 businesses
it's crazy to see there's a lot to do in
this space and
i presume i'll have you know there'll be
other people getting involved i mean
soon
when you think about uh the businesses
is it fair to say that your investment
strategy is essentially to invest in the
infrastructure uh and then your benefit
you're benefiting from like the overall
industry growth and the kind of that
index approaches you're basically
betting hey the industry is going to be
you know much larger hundreds of percent
larger uh in the future
and you want to bet on businesses that
are going to win as long as the industry
grows is that kind of a fair
characterization that's that's exactly
right um
you know that's exactly right i
i think uh you know we want to pay a
reasonable uh multiple of of revenue and
and earnings as well
um i mean i don't think there's a
company that we paid more than 10 times
revenue for
um you know we're we're there there are
so many opportunities out there we're
very active in the secondary market as
well we speak to companies directly
um
you know i i'm not really
willing to pay 25 or 30 times revenue
um
and there are great companies that we've
just passed on
um that will grow a lot uh just because
you know we don't have to buy everything
there there are lots of of great
companies but
um yeah i would say these are companies
that we think are core to the ecosystem
and you know the approach really was
it's a 300 billion dollar
in you know late 1920 300 300 billion
dollar world
and we think it's going to 10 trillion
and so that's 30x and if it goes 30x
if we have a basket uh portfolio
uh diversified nicely
of you know sort of broadly what you're
calling picks and shovels businesses
that are constructing you know the rails
of this new digital asset ecosystem
you know the odds are the portfolio is
going to go up and i we don't need a 30x
to be happy
um but we actually put that 10 t
obviously you know we're we're putting
our our uh you know we're eating our own
cooking on this one i mean i put it in
the title of the fun so
um
you know a portfolio
i think broadly is going to have such
wind at its back
that it should do well and again you can
see from the names that we purchased
um
that you know it is it is uh diversified
into those buckets and then these
businesses broadly do different types of
things so
talk to me about um the biggest surprise
as you've been deploying the capital i
know you've deployed a very large
portion of the 750 million dollars
already uh what's been the biggest
surprise to you whether it's you know as
you've dug deeper into the companies
talking to entrepreneurs talking to
investors what surprised you well
let me see i mean i guess i would say
that you know one of the hesitations
that many people we spoke with initially
had was they said well dan that's great
your team is great you know everyone has
connections in the network in the space
but how are you going to procure these
blocks of stock you know
um you know i had the portfolio more or
less broadly
uh outlined
before we launched i said to investors
you know this is what i'm interested in
you know we had five leaders and five
backups and i said
broadly within these you know for the
three buckets within these 30 companies
you know we're going to have a portfolio
and
you know hopefully we'll get you know
some of our leaders uh we won't have to
go to our backups but this is what it's
going to look like and almost every
person said well how are you going to do
that how you get maybe the stock's not
available etc etc biggest surprise
is that it's been very easy
to source
uh the the equity in the businesses that
we wanted very easy versus expectations
and um you know and i think that's why
the lps also keep asking for you know
when is the next fund we allocated very
quickly much more quickly than we
thought but again at reasonable
valuations we weren't reaching for the
moon or anything we just we said
you know these are the types of
businesses we're interested in
you know we've approached a lot of the
companies directly we have you know have
built good relationships um you know i
think we're still the only
fund
i think out there that is focused
exclusively and only on mid to late
stage uh companies in the digital asset
ecosystem so
you know and i think people in the space
know that um
and so it's not you know as you know
it's a very flat space uh you can reach
out to someone on twitter um it's not
it's not that that hard
and if people feel that you know you are
bringing new
capital to the space and i think we are
i think we're bringing you know people
joke with me that oh dan you know you're
doing you're doing crypto for boomers
i mean it's sort of true
um you know we're bringing like
completely new capital to this space and
we're allocating it i think to some of
the smartest guys
and i'm saying to myself these guys they
know what to do with it they're much
smarter than i am
uh and certainly on the weeds you know
getting deep into the weeds and they're
going to be able to pivot to where the
action is to where the business is to
the places that really need capital so
i'm in a sense
really you know i think some of these
businesses already are budding
conglomerates and also in a way like vc
funds as well because
you know some of the businesses they're
snapping up these smaller companies
um and they're incorporating them into
their operating businesses so
you know in a way
they know
what smaller companies are going to be
successful almost better than the vcs
because they're incorporating them into
their bigger businesses so
um
i would say the biggest surprise was
that we haven't had difficulty and also
in the future i mean there are a lot of
companies out there i mean there's quite
a long pipeline of companies that have
approached us or that we've marked um
you know
that are that we think are interesting
and worth investing in
when you think about um
the industry at large one of the things
that comes up a lot is regulation
obviously we're seeing it in all
different forms and fashion some of it
seems to be a tailwind some of it seems
to be a headwind how do you talk to
legacy
kind of market investors people who
think about regulation a lot want
to understand that there's certainty
from a regulation standpoint what are
those conversations about
yeah i think
the one thing that i try to you know
make very clear to the lps
um is that crypto
you know is a global business
bitcoin ethereum it's global all the the
things popping up in the ecosystem it's
global and if you look at total world
volume
uh spot and futures i think the us is 10
of world volume so i keep telling people
listen stop telling me about the sec and
the treasury and all this stuff i get it
yeah the us is going slow
they're putting speed bumps out there i
personally am not so sure they they know
what they're doing
um they'll figure it out uh they'll
figure it out but
for the investments that we're making
they're all global businesses and some
of them are us but we have some you know
we have a non-regulated business in
there but he's buttoned up he's smart
he's not doing any he's doing his kyc
we're not you know concerned um about
like any issues it's just that he
doesn't operate in the united states and
that's fine again people in the u.s
think everything is always just about
the us and in the last 30 40 years and
before
really since the war i guess that's been
true
um but
you know
this may be the first time
that from an a technology innovation and
financial innovation perspective the us
is definitely not in the lead
and it could be you know i think that
this is an opportunity i've been saying
this for two years
for the legislators here for people in
government
dig deep understand what's going on here
and my goodness i mean incentivize
innovation forget about like over
regulating it and being difficult and
clamping down and all of this stuff
um this is the future and we don't want
to be left behind
and you know i tell my lps these are
these companies they're diversified
globally
um you know even the us ones so
i just
you know i i think it takes a little bit
of time for people to understand that um
i mean just think about how many you
know there are probably note operators
in every country that exists in the
world right
of course you can't say that about other
assets
of course
i've got my brother john here he's got a
couple questions for you
yeah hey dan thank you for doing this
it's really nice to meet you um 10t is
an awesome name by the way attention
holdings i love that uh well it's only
awesome if we're right
that is true that is true um so i'm
curious about you were talking about
investing in the infrastructure of kind
of the digital asset economy what
excites you the most about that so i've
seen that you guys have done investments
into kraken ledger sas um like what is
exciting to you about that is it the
lightning network is it the hardware is
it kind of the um the exchanges like
what what are you excited about moving
forward
yeah i mean you know i take a little bit
of a pedestrian uh approach to it in the
sense that
you know what excites me about the
businesses we're buying
is the fact that they're making a lot of
money
right i'm an investor okay and the guys
who are winning and know how to win and
know how to build businesses
um those are the guys i want to invest
in that's different from you know
projects that i think are cool that i
think could work
um again i'm not a venture capitalist i
i i don't have the ability to
make skilled judgments about you know
these budding enterprises
um you know
in a sense
you know i'm letting in a way i'm not
letting but i'm i'm not making these
investments at sea or in the a rounds
or really even b i mean we're usually
focused on b plus and c and d
i don't mind paying a higher valuation
um you know a higher market valuation
if the company has established itself
already um
you know because
the space is growing so quickly
um
i i just as i said i'm just trying to
build a broad diversified
um bet for
um you know for the traditional investor
and i'll tell you you look at the list
of companies for rlp base i mean most of
them have never heard of these
businesses before so just think about
that never
and so that's why i say i think we've
we've tapped into a a whole new uh type
of investor base
um
yeah and i mean so i again
the the criteria really is this
threshold
um you know do they have a
you know are they are
it's not not a business looking for a
business right it's a business that's
already established itself and is
dominant in its space
dan when you think about uh moving
forward are you going to just continue
to um allocate capital to the space uh
do you think it's something where once
you get the money invested then you'll
kind of sit and harvest it how do you
think about kind of future plans
yeah i mean i think look if there are
opportunities out there reasonable
evaluations i think we'll keep going in
in some form or another i mean
um you know if if i look out and there
aren't
opportunities or everything is trading
at 30 40 times revenue then i think that
would you know we take we take a rest
um
but as i said i mean just think about it
one year ago
20 businesses worth over a billion
dollars today there are 70 and that's
not that's not just multiple expansion
and in some cases you know that's
massive revenue expansion
and so you know just in very like simple
terms i mean we all know the volume just
the volume at the exchanges is up 5x
from last year i mean that's 500 percent
and so there are huge knock-on effects
as the number of wallets increase as
adoption increases
um it's really it's it's exponential and
so as long as there are opportunities
out there i think we'll continue to
allocate capital
i think that uh that makes sense where
can we send people to find you on
twitter or find more information about
what you're doing
well i'm dtap cap on twitter
um
but you know we have a website 10t
fund you know if you just punch it into
google as i
you know you'll you get to our website
and
um you know we have all sorts of
information there
um
i think we may even have our
the uh interview that you and i did last
on there uh on under the educational
section but you know that's a good place
that's a good place to go the website
i love it i love it listen you uh you've
been ahead of the curve you continued to
uh to surprise to the upside just like
bitcoin and everything else so uh keep
it up i think this is uh awesome and
then obviously the portfolio that you
guys have built is a list of very
impressive names so i think that any
founder who uh who has the opportunity
to partner with you guys is uh is pretty
intelligent if they go ahead and they
pursue that
well thanks pomp and i i hope that some
of your early stage investments
uh grow into you know 10 t investments
so i'm looking forward to us doing some
business as well maybe down the line i'm
going to send them all to you like
listen dan's the smartest guy that i
know go ahead and take all of his money
[Laughter]
all right pump anyway thank you very
much for having me really enjoyed this
absolutely thanks so much for doing it
everyone make sure that you go check out
10t fund.com or you can go follow dan on
twitter at d
tap cap all capitalized by the way which
is uh is my favorite thing about your
twitter um all right sir thank you so
much
thanks all right bye
legend 750 million dollars
just knows what he's doing
you think so 10t yeah
10 you like that name huh yeah why do
you like that name so much it's looking
for 10t
[Music]
john's gonna start hitting me just
randomly in conversation with a 10t 10t
this big company for 10t to be honest i
think that he's bearish
i mean if we're just talking bitcoin 10t
you know whatever else
i like how he looks at all the different
uh different avenues he wants to
diversify in a specific space yeah
ooh people are saying they got their
adam shoes where
real quick uh let's see jordy can you
hand me the box
by the way
surprise
you know what we're gonna do today this
is a wild idea nobody knows i'm about to
do just toss with me it's fine
all right here's what we're gonna do for
those that haven't seen these yet
this
sick box
is a box from adams if you don't know
adams
adams is by far the most comfortable
shoes in the world
when you get the box
you can open it
look at that look at that you ain't got
a shoe box that does that
i do
and in this box
is a shoe
this shoe is a collaboration you know
big time stuff over here big dog stuff
collaboration between atoms and me
it's a bitcoin shoe
has the bitcoin b right there
inside of the shoe
is the nice
probably hard to see nice 21 million for
21 million bitcoin
on the bottom
i think it's called the soul of the shoe
we are all satoshi
right there so when you put these on
your feet
you become like
what what's the guy's name in uh sandlot
benny the jet benny the jet
put the shoes on you come like benny the
jet
you can steal home plate real easy yeah
john likes that look at john's like dan
that was a good reference thinking back
to i've seen the sandlot that's for sure
yeah he ain't seen rocky but he's seen
the sand lot you put these shoes on
right here you become like betty the jet
the bitcoin shoes now here's the best
part about these shoes they are super
comfortable
there's two things you got to know one
atoms
was started by my two friends wakas and
sidra they got one of the craziest
stories i know they literally grew up in
pakistan didn't even have access to the
internet didn't know anything about the
internet didn't speak english etc until
like six seven years ago they ended up
coming to the united states went through
yc they created this company atoms
created these shoes absolutely exploded
everyone from alexis ohanian all the way
on down has invested they've worked with
etc
and
these shoes
that have the bitcoin symbol on them
as a collaborator collaborator
collaborator yeah no might be getting
paid you know i'd be raking in the
shekels
but i'm not gonna do that
a hundred percent
of the money
that i get from this
i'm donating to the human rights
foundation's bitcoin developer fund
so people are asking where they can buy
them already so
these shoes
i believe the website let me just make
sure here before i give you guys fake
news i don't do fake news oh yeah here
we go
i'm gonna put it in here adams.com
bitcoin
you can do it now here's why adams
is in these shoes i'm taking the time
out of my day after a red eye to talk to
you about them
one when you buy these shoes money gets
donated to the bitcoin developer fund at
the human rights foundation me i donate
the money to them so i make nothing off
of this
two
is
you walk around in sweet shoes
and you're comfortable and you help fund
bitcoin development big deal
three
is
adams has been accepting bitcoin
for a while now you can buy these shoes
leveraging
regular bitcoin or lightning network etc
go right through the payment fleet
you're paying bitcoin you can pay in
dollars
i'm sure that they would even take
whatever other fiat currency you have if
they really wanted to
the last thing is
that you're supporting immigrant
entrepreneurs as well which is probably
my favorite part actually
because
adams
is one of the companies that is the
perfect example
of why america is so great the american
dream
they ship international they ship
domestically i like the shoes
you should like the shoes too if you
don't like the shoes then you got
problems
but you should go check them out
my brother is calling me joe is calling
me right now
hold on
hey we're live on the show you better
not say anything stupid what's up
no we're only at 1.2 000 likes get the
lights up people
did joe just call into the show on my
cell phone to try to tell people to get
the likes off cheers and the comments
hate me
are you hating in the comments
yeah i was giving you crap no one cares
what time you took a flight dude
oh i jumped off the red i jumped off the
red eye no excuses
bro
you're laying in bed right now you're
not even here at work
you took the day off you're on vacation
i'm certainly not laying in bed well you
got enough time to call into the show so
you should have been here
yeah i took a break from making money
what
you know what joe's doing right now
judge probably sitting there in his
boxer briefs in front of the computer
watching us laughing as he says stupid
stuff and sees our reaction
dumb uh no i just called in to say get
the likes up i wish i was on the show
yeah but you're not you got five wish
you were here joe
remember when remember when you called
john and john didn't answer
uh yeah john ignored my call i saw it
live on the show
[Laughter]
all right
hey go buy adam's shoes we don't have
time to talk to you anymore
all right see y'all later
i'm never answering his call live on the
show again there's a reason i didn't
answer the first time
damn i know john's coming out all right
adams.com bitcoin go check out the shoes
they're awesome talk to me one
john's got a pair now they got 21 21
million inside as well
how dope are these and
you can go and you can support bitcoin
collaboration i'm pumping them up
yeah founders are really cool have them
at the founders very cool very smart
yeah oh johnny with the endorsement okay
it's all right
that's it for today
that's it
[Music]
we'll be back tomorrow we'll be better
tomorrow we got will clemente coming on
we're gonna talk about bitcoin what the
hell is going on with the price
i don't even know what to ask you guys
to do
oh oh oh
hold on a second sorry i forgot
i'll give away these shoes
oh yeah i'll give away one of the other
pair i'll give away one pair right now
here's what we're gonna do
is
this is only for the real ones that are
left too yeah yeah yeah if you left
early you suck you you missed out here's
what i want you guys to do
we'll do a little shark attack and i'll
pick one person
let's do
this
we're going to tweet at adams
so here i'm putting in the chat right
now this is there
that is their twitter account go to
their twitter account
and i want you to tweet at whereadams
where adams is the name
and when you tweet at them i want you to
simply say
one thing
two things actually
pomp sent me
hashtag pay me in bitcoin
and tweet
at their account at whereadams so just
like this
yo at where adams
pomp sent me hashtag
pay me in bitcoin they're going to be so
mad that we're doing this but i don't
care go ahead tweet that use the hashtag
i'll pick one person and
we will mail you
one of the bitcoin shoes
that's it for today
don't say i didn't ever do anything for
you all
great luck good luck to everyone
johnny last closing words plain a left
she just walked off the stage she's her
stage sex
she's out
ricky williams was on the show today i
mean if we're not someone was just
hating they're like they're like get
better guess i was like who do you want
us to have ricky
williams whoever that person is maybe
that they we should get we'll get you to
call in next time yeah you find out who
that was all right
we gotta go
yeah luke i'm done man four and a half
hours of sleep me and john just out here
rocking joe didn't come to work today
matt and jordy absolutely killing it
plana left the show early whatever we're
ready to rock and roll pay your credit
card off show you an air energy we'll be
back with summer fridays tomorrow see
you guys later
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]